foreign
[Laughter]
real British people in there
hahaha
live and in person yeah live in person I
was entertained I was yeah I got some of
them on video
we did yeah I should put that well I put
the one video on Facebook but that
wasn't the main one that she was in I
haven't uploaded it yet I took pictures
of the food too but I haven't got those
up either because I forgot
yeah
I forgot I did I did go on TripAdvisor
and give him a good review oh good good
because she said our our server uh
Elaine she said hey if you go give us a
good review on TripAdvisor and you
mentioned her name on there then she
gets an extra hundred dollars like at
the end of the month like the people
with the most mentions or whatever yeah
you know what I mean so there's that
whole thing but yeah it was like I I'm
glad we found that place it's only like
10 miles from here yeah and it's in
lovely downtown Mount Dora
which is a lovely historic district not
far from here I'll have to go down there
and fart around sometime yeah but yeah
it was good I had I had a chicken curry
pie
Jenny's dressed up for her birthday
she's looking good
legs looking good
boobs all that idea I'm getting too
popular on this show
I'm getting popular about talking
because I'm talking about Jenny all the
time
and uh threatening to open up the only
fans uh but it's not gonna happen people
all right don't don't get
laughs
our only fans material is just between
me and jam you're still full of [ __ ] Tom
not in a good moods I'm trying to psych
myself up I was well you're not in a
good mood yeah well I was kind of
halfway sleeping well that's the thing
like wait yeah I mean I woke up really
early I usually do anyway but I woke up
at like 5 15 and then because I had to
go to the bathroom again like I had to
get up like three times to pee in the
middle of the night so I get up at 5 15
and then I'm like okay I'm gonna get
back in bed and sleep for another couple
hours and then of course I couldn't so
like so I stayed there for an hour and
then I was like [ __ ] it so 6 15 I got up
so then like we went to the restaurant
and then we went and picked up the cake
because I went to Publix bakery and got
a cake man that Cake's delicious yeah
wow it's rich as [ __ ] though yeah you
really have to eat it in small people's
still showing up we're gonna start here
in a minute but um it's caramel pecan
yeah it's just too rich I gotta get
little bitty slices of that it's good
when you get down when you get down to
the fat part of it that's where all that
frosting is I was just like I was
stopped dead in my tracks I could well
you have to think too that we had just
come back from the British pub please if
you got fish and chips and they I mean
the fish they gave that was no joke
massive yeah I'm kind of glad it was
delicious like he gave me a bite but I
was like I'm kind of glad I didn't get
that because there's no way I could have
eaten even half of that yeah and uh
Elaine the the waitress she's like a
British pub waitress I got it man I got
her on video for tattoos and everything
you know and she didn't really give me a
choice I just said she's gonna have you
you can have fish and chips that's what
I am well that's it
I said they got caught they got hotties
you're gonna have the haddock get the
Hat hatting
this is had it because it had it was
more because it's much better
big old piece I said okay get the head
because I I let her order
after her t-shirt which had a British
flag on it and said I'm not yelling I'm
British yeah which I thought was very
funny yeah
yeah that's a cool place I got a nice
bar in there and everything she's
bragging that she got her an American
man
[Laughter]
I got it on video I think it I think
it's on there I think I think it
recorded I was laughing yeah because
it's like I gave it to him to record so
I don't know if he I don't know if it
recorded it or not
um thank you
okay yeah but I'm not getting much sleep
the my [ __ ] new protocols [ __ ] got
me on some [ __ ] they're just freaking
sleep for a few hours and then wake up
and then go back to sleep and then wake
up welcome to my world well like I said
after a while I just kind of like [ __ ]
it and I'm just like it's not even light
out and I'm just like well I might as
well just get up because I'm just laying
here bored so we'll get some work done
I'm gonna come way back on the [ __ ]
stack
bring the dosage back it's it's kind of
[ __ ] with me not being able to sleep
it's burning my legs up man
yeah
putting welts on it that shit's [ __ ]
having some kind of weird reaction to it
yeah it's [ __ ] up looking yeah [ __ ]
Tran yes there's Trend in there and
masterov who is your idea nobody told
you that nobody told you turn you into a
[ __ ] Minotaur
or something with a bunch of welts that
can't sleep yeah I don't know if that's
worth it
that's work it's working real bad it's
[ __ ] I can feel it just peeling fat
off me
but um
yeah it's good it's just not that good
you know what I mean not that good where
you're taking that much of it I'm gonna
come down some I think I think it's too
much
try to get it I'm not in any hurry you
know what I mean it's not like I'm
trying to prep for a show or something
you know everybody wishing me happy
birthday
Zach says happy birthday again thank you
for some reason I kept having the
weirdest dream over and over again last
night I went what what what was it are
you gonna tell us or are you gonna be
like
Tom's welt can't sleep oh no someone
else Tom's welts can't sleep
yeah the injection sites kind of pop up
a little bit after about the day after
like little
a little half a little ping pong balls
in there around for a day or two and
then they come down you gotta
it never mind
yeah why are you talking about a little
injection why are you talking about your
welts yeah
trying to [ __ ] dilute it with [ __ ]
more mild [ __ ] testosterone and stuff
but like I said I'm open about what I do
y'all know
well you know I don't know it's not like
it was back in the days when dudes lie
about [ __ ] at my age you can do what you
got to do
I had yeah I had a couple messages today
that uh
I had somebody message me and said hey
your Facebook thing said that your
birthday today and that you were 50.
it's like I thought you were 36. oh yeah
that's good yeah that's what they say
that's the same guy at Circle K said
and I was like well that's good I guess
his manly lumps says tailing right it's
like they're temporary I don't know if
this was really the way we wanted to
start the show out but
see that's how she's coming right there
anyway this is a good episode though
well I let Tom pick the episode because
like he kept like I was in here like
trying to do something I had like a
something that I had to do and like so
he's like going through and he's like
what about this one and I was like we
did that one already what about this one
we did that when we're ready too and
then like I couldn't find I was looking
for my list because I wrote down a list
of all the ones we've done before and I
couldn't [ __ ] find it I don't know
where it is this one's from maybe Pookie
ate it this was from 2012. I don't know
what season that is it's season five
it's season five season five episode
five right there's still a lot of good
ones in in season five
and uh this one I think has a pretty
credible Witnesses and the case is
strong it kind of matches up with
certain things that I saw uh it you know
like it's kind of like that bad house I
was in but this one's actually
it's mostly dreams mostly having dreams
but this one's actually moving stuff and
there's
uh apparitions and it does move objects
doesn't it yeah
or is it just does it ever actually move
an object
kind of
hmm
sort of I kind of I kind of got confused
because it seemed like I know that the
episode is called Dark dreams so they
didn't necessarily but a lot of it is
dreams but they don't really like
I don't know they do kind of say that
it's dreams but it kind of they're kind
of like blurring the line yeah they burn
a lot they blur the lines sometimes
because the person who's having the
dream thinks it's real
and right and you as the audience think
it's real too and then they wake up
and I don't think it actually ever moved
that object
in the waking world but they were
dreaming that it was moving objects
because remember the first thing he does
is that he thought the damn pitchers on
the bed next to him yeah that's right
we're moving I don't know if that ever
really happened I think he dreamed that
they moved the only thing because I was
sitting there thinking well is this
whole thing just like him having
nightmares and they've made a whole show
about that but
that he did say that like um that his
kids saw The Apparition saw The
Apparition like saw the same guy that
would pick him up in his dreams so
that's why he thought it was real right
so I'm like okay I'll allow it yeah
because other than that I think it would
have just been all Dreams yeah I think
it's pretty much all his dreams and
people seeing apparitions and um uh
feelings of dread like you're being
watched and uh you know like going down
in the basement it feels bad there uh
dreams and Visions paranormal dreams
to what they are which that one house
that I was in had I had those
they're weird dreams that seems like
they're coming from outside and they're
a message that was the one where I was
kept seeing the visions of the damn
starving puppies inside the pipes
oh that's right I remember you telling
that about that yeah I kept being shown
that and I don't know what it meant some
of the pipes went straight down and I
could see it like
x-ray vision pipe going straight down
the pipe isn't there in my room in
reality it's only there in the dream
imagine like next to your bed there's a
[ __ ] five inch pipe going straight
down into the floor and you can see an
x-ray vision of that pipe going all the
way down through all three floors and
going into the basement and then about
another 30 feet down underneath the
basement floor into a chamber filled
with [ __ ] starving puppies that's
what I was shown that's pretty [ __ ] up
yeah very disturbing you know and it
felt it shown it was shown to me as if
it was something important
and
I I didn't even really want to know
you know what I mean I didn't want to
know if there's any kind of damn chamber
you know down underneath there I'm I'm
afraid I probably would have had to
check because I'd be like there could be
real puppies down there I have to help
them
well they would have been a long day I
don't think that's what it was murder
Hornet says lay off the acid yeah
I have dreams Zach says could I asked
him about the weird dream he said
someone was chasing me into the yard of
some crappy motel and I kept doing
something different every time but I
kept falling like in a video game with
multiple choices God I hate [ __ ]
dreams like that yeah next Dimension
media says I know being from Florida
this is not your first rodeo referring
to the hurricane uh but I hope you guys
stay safe this week yeah we'll try I
mean like I said the house is supposedly
it's yeah built for Hurricane standards
that doesn't necessarily mean anything
if it's like really bad but
the shitty thing is that if the power
goes out because then like the power
might be out for like days and days I
got generators we got a generator I got
two generators we got two generators and
uh bit and one of them is they're both
good one they're new one of them's a
[ __ ] powerful one but I don't know I
don't think it can run all the air
conditioners and I don't have the hook
up for the side of the house yet maybe
one or two grand to get that hooked up
yeah that's a little steep sorry so it
was a high priority but that's a lot of
money
um to just pay all the ones we still
have those that we sell those two window
units don't we
yeah I got all the unit winning units
and all kinds of stuff so I can run that
yeah and I'll just write attention cords
up put them in the one room like we did
put them in the windows and run an
extension cord up the awning yeah have
them out there in the back that's okay I
just need to get fuel but I'm not gonna
get fuel until I know that this thing's
gonna be heading towards because they
always kind of like tell you I mean it's
kind of kind of like they're coming well
they don't really know like where it's
gonna go so they don't want to like
leave it too late and then everybody's
like well we didn't have time to get
ready but it's like you know it then
they kind of like air on the opposite
side where when it's still like 700
miles away they're like well it could
hit you so get all your [ __ ] together
which is probably like a good thing to
do anyway but if I'm gonna go down there
and get fuel I'm gonna get at least 100
worth of fuel now I'll burn it in cars
over time but that's just another
hundred dollars that I don't really
can't really afford I don't get paid
till the end of the month you know what
I'm talking about yeah I got it but I
don't want to run that low you know yeah
I mean you know there's only a week left
in this month so I don't I think chances
are we're gonna be all right but we'll
we'll know we'll you never know you
never just keep an eye on it I mean too
early it's way too early that's what I
mean like I said it's good to keep an
eye on it but they do try to like warn
you away ahead of time and sometimes it
like freaks everybody I think it's gonna
hit south of Tampa
yeah I mean we still we're still gonna
get some of it probably unless it
drastically veers off course which it
absolutely could do because I've seen it
do that before everybody's like oh my
God here it comes here it comes and then
it goes yeah I hope it doesn't [ __ ] up
too much because I'm supposed to go to
Disney with my sister next Sunday yeah
so I hope that she could turn and go
towards Louisiana that's what I'm saying
like I've seen that apps that actual
thing completely happened where because
I think when I lived in Daytona they
were like oh my God this is coming like
right up you guys's [ __ ] and then
like at the last minute it was like and
it just like went up like that and it
didn't even we got nothing Louisiana
Mississippi Gulf Coast is like a [ __ ]
Prime Zone that place been slammed over
and over and over again
so it's just as bad as Florida and it
could it could it could easily just turn
it they do it yeah well yeah it's
weather so many factors yeah
you know and if it goes out in that Gulf
it'll speed up
because of the the water's warmer there
and the [ __ ] hurricane speeds up out
in the Gulf
when as it starts heading towards
Louisiana Mississippi warm water
shallower or something I don't know
something to do with the way
water flow is there yeah okay we can go
ahead and start on Glenn little says uh
sorry Jen happy birthday upside as
you'll have less of a [ __ ] uh give less
of a [ __ ] next year still looking good
thank you very much yeah you should see
the booze man huh yeah I was getting
ready to grab on these things man right
here on the show that's all I wouldn't
get any dams I wouldn't get your Super
Chat money for it though
so there's no point too there's no point
in it
now she's like she's looking uh
molestable
molestable yeah that's a good word yeah
it's not the trend talking you're
looking good lately
well thank you oh I have to show you
this card yeah that Tom gave me because
look at that kitty on there doing Kung
Fu I could yes he's either doing Kung Fu
or doing mind control he's doing Kung Fu
he's he's a ninja oh that's right he's a
ninja also kind of looks like mind
control though yeah let's just say in
the middle something about the ninja
yeah it does say about it he's doing
kofu
yeah I'm like a Birthday [ __ ]
looks so serious yeah that's like what
Pookie's face is like she was like very
very serious so let's never can't go
wrong never can't go wrong with candy
cards
that's I kind of feel like the last few
years we've just kind of like we just
keep giving each other yeah just because
it's like if I see a card that has a cat
that looks like Pokey or a cat that's
doing like a funny [ __ ] Zach says he's
gonna send us some more Super chats when
his new job kicks in okay he got a new
job yeah good thanks at a print shop
he's very excited about it uh Danny
Rowling said Jenny officially graduated
to Cougar goth status by turning 50 yeah
but really looks like he's 139 just
saying hey I'll [ __ ] take it I'll
take it she's on been on that bicycle
man I'm doing a diet and [ __ ]
supplements and [ __ ] and she's God I
just ride so much so many [ __ ] miles
yeah 30 miles a day if I if I rode like
in real life I'd have been life like
ridden across the country by now you
should see your legs her legs are
looking real good
I'm gonna do if we're gonna do a photo
shoot
you and legs and the heels and [ __ ]
[ __ ] our boys keep you know you guys
know I got this shoe problem okay the
shoe problem yeah I got a shoe problem
I do it's not so bad where I just need
the shoe and don't need the woman
if there's a woman and there's a shoe
it's just [ __ ] mine yeah he's just
[ __ ] mind-blowing I don't understand
it I don't understand it either some
kind of fetish I picked up over the
years and the more uncomfortable the
shoe the better yeah and it's got to be
kind of [ __ ] really high because then
I'm always very uncomfortable man they
gotta look like like I'm gonna break my
ankles yeah like that [ __ ] they gotta
look like bondage [ __ ] implements and
[ __ ] yeah I guess it's kind of like the
Chinese dudes in the foot binding type
yeah that that fetish the small foot as
possible or something but I don't know
just uh that's something about a real
aggressive looking shoes they don't have
to
they don't have to have
super skinny heels either like you know
some of the stuff that you know like
platforms I like those too you know big
old [ __ ] golf platforms and
so they don't have to be little I don't
really like little she's like big shoes
I like them both it just depends you
know
yeah guys that I wish girls still wore
pantyhose everywhere like when I was in
high school
I mean I usually I don't usually I don't
like pantyhose like the like the nude
ones I like uh I like black tights
though yeah I wear black tights if I'm
wearing a skirt
but I don't like nude painting those I
have white ones too but I'm trying to
pretend to break her that break me away
[ __ ] not wearing [ __ ] stuff that's
nude or just going bare legged that she
looks so [ __ ] cute
I don't know I just it looks so cute you
got good legs I just don't like to just
saying
Zach says how sad is it that I never
learned to ride a bike I can never stay
balanced as a little kid a bicycle yeah
damn
well you know it happens
or something
well I know a lot of people that don't
know how to swim either
you know what I mean my grandma never
learned because she was afraid of
putting her first things that they put
her face out of the water yeah I learned
to swim when I was really really little
I love to swim and it's basically in a
Southern family they throw your ass in
the water the baby you better learn how
to swim but you're gonna be around water
yeah I don't think I wasn't that young
but when I was little like we we were we
lived in an apartment complex they had a
pool and like my dad was the pool guy
those Creeks [ __ ] lakes and [ __ ] you
got you gotta teach you
in this environment you the kid has to
be Swimming by three or four you know I
was a toddler I could swim
yeah it was before I went to school for
sure I don't remember but the weird
thing is I don't remember I don't
remember learning yeah I don't remember
learning I remember learning
it's kind of like I don't remember
learning how to swim and I don't
remember learning how to read yeah I
just knew how to do it I know I know it
took me to the pool and floated and then
I was I could swim before I knew it I
could swim underneath the water and
everything yeah and I I could speak but
I don't really remember it yeah that
must have been two three maybe I mean
because my mom was real into like pool
and beach and everything like that so
she always I mean I was the youngest or
the oldest kid but um you know so I was
four before my brother was born but she
used to take us to the beach all the
time so I'm pretty sure I knew how to
swim before my brother was born
um yeah Zach said uh swimming is my
favorite exercise but I've never had a
house with a pool yeah I've never lived
in a house with a pool either we've
lived like our last house the the
community had a pool like the house
didn't have a pool but I've lived in
like some apartment complexes that had a
pool
but that's about it I couldn't get away
with it just because even when I was in
California as a little kid we were
always going up to the uh Sequoia and
[ __ ] Lake clarko and stuff so you
even not even have anything to do with
the South just the the lifestyle we had
in California you had to teach your kids
to swim early or you couldn't trust them
because you're going to be
in the campsites and around all that
water in Florida like a lot of people's
houses different schools and you can't
yeah if you don't want your kid
wandering off and falling in there and
drowning yeah they have to learn how to
swim so yeah I mean like my friend when
she had a kid like she took that kid to
swimming classes when that kid was like
still in diapers you know what I mean
like teaching her how to swim which a
lot of people do here which and you
can't blame them yeah you know we want
you want you know how to swim once you
know how to ride a bicycle your parents
like cut you loose we were like feral
going down into the storm drains and
going to the [ __ ] swamps up in
Mississippi and just going anywhere
you'd be all right didn't worry about
serial killers and [ __ ] probably should
have but that was rare you know
and another thing is that we were never
alone we always traveled in big packs of
boys with with packs of dogs with the
boys that's another thing
little little boys and dogs are about
the same
but wherever we went we always had three
or four [ __ ] dogs with us too
it's kind of like babysitters dogs are
better than little boys yeah similar
interests
chasing [ __ ] digging [ __ ] up
Danny Rowling said yeah the Ghost
Soldier episode definitely had a
birthday cake scene but wasn't scary at
all no being told by a discount like
that's why we thought about it because
it had the birthday thing going on but
then I was like why don't I just let Tom
pick one that he likes he's like I don't
really like that episode and I was like
well okay why don't you just pick one
then so he picked this one I like this
episode because it's it sounds credible
the the tail is not super wild
um and the family is it seems to be
pretty credible the guy telling the
story is just a friend of guy you know
and they got a guy playing him in in the
episode I I looks kind of looks just
like him I kept losing track of which
was the original sometimes I get
confused they had veneers on the fake
one his [ __ ] smile would be [ __ ]
shining throughout the darkness and [ __ ]
and um then they switch over to show the
real guy during his interview and he he
did kind of have a big big old smile
like almost like almost Gary Busey level
yes not like not that extreme but yeah
but kind of Along on that Spectrum he
had just a big on the Gary Busey
Spectrum yeah but like a few steps down
from here
not [ __ ] nothing he seems like a nice
man yeah
um I would say more like Gary Busey's
son what's his name Jake Busey more like
that
yeah although Jake Busey's got some
pretty big choppers yeah but yeah maybe
not as crazy one not as crazy as with
you but that's well yeah and the thing
about this okay so they actually did I
kind of feel like
a lot of times on a haunting maybe they
started doing this later on like after
the first four seasons but I feel like a
lot of the episodes that we did before
like they'll talk about the case on the
show but then I'll find out later that
the person on there like wrote a book
about it but on this episode the guy had
written a book about it and they
mentioned it like at the end of the
episode so this guy named Chris Gibbons
he wrote a book called trespass that
came out in 2011. yeah I think it's just
that Novella so you can get this you can
get the book of this trespass and
there's a website trespass.com evidently
yeah so I don't know if it's still up or
not because I looked on Amazon and it's
like on Goodreads and it only has like
four reviews
um so and like three of them are like
super super positive and like one of
them is super super negative okay so you
never know what's going on so I don't
really know what's going on and like the
one print one that they had was like a
thousand dollars so maybe like it's out
of print wow a thousand so I don't know
wow I don't know and I read a little bit
of like an interview that they had done
with him when they did because
apparently he wrote the book first
and then a haunting approached him
that's how it that's how it seemed like
it somebody's trying to scalp one of his
books for a thousand bucks
yeah well it happens a lot like
especially if um if there's not many if
there's not many of them out there like
they figure hey why not maybe some crazy
person with more money than sense will
come across it yeah and want it really
bad I'm like it's not likely but okay it
doesn't cost anything to put it up there
I guess
Jeffy art said Jenny's birthday is so
epic this guy's down here in South
Florida are ripping open stay dry
everyone yeah I kind of feel like that's
uh I think they're getting some of that
hurricane action down there all right
I kept getting like on my little thing
um that gives you the little weather
updates it kept saying hurricane on
there I'm like there's not a hurricane
outside right now what the [ __ ] are you
talking about and then it just kept
saying flood and then it kept saying
tropical storm and I'm just like tell me
this stuff when the [ __ ] is like
actually coming like it's still like a
day or two weird things that's what I'm
saying yeah that's what I thought and
honestly when I looked at the unless it
speeded up from the last time I looked
at it I thought like it probably wasn't
even gonna really affect this area until
like later in the week yeah unless I'm
I'm you know unless like I said it's
speeded up maybe it did
I don't know probably just gonna be a
tropical storm by the time he gets here
well I don't know the longer that it's
over water that's usually bad because
that makes it more powerful if it's over
land it usually like weakens some so
there's that all right so are we going
to start talking about this episode are
you in are you in like a good mood now
I'm starting to warm up are you starting
to warm up yeah okay because I don't
want you to be over there groused in and
grabbing what I want
this was the episode you picked yeah I
was just sleeping
well you got a nap I didn't I've been up
since 5 15. I didn't you oh I've been
through this already yeah that's what I
was at so I'm sleepy too but that's just
that's just how how it works you're an
adult you have to be sleepy all the time
it's just kind of like a thing okay
that's just how it happened some [ __ ]
there man well it's true though okay all
right so like I said this one's called
Dark dreams season five episode five
so this takes place in Grand Rapids
Michigan by the way I did not have time
to type out my notes so I'm reading from
my little notebook which I just like
wrote down really quick like while we're
watching the episode last night
so as I mentioned this is the Gibbons
family now Chris Gibbons is the dad and
then he he's an attorney right they said
he was an attorney like with his own
practice and his wife's name is k they
didn't say what she did
um and they have like four kids their
names are Andrew Sammy or Samuel
something like that Sarah and Patrick
now all of them have like a traditional
Irish band it's one of those family
bands I looked it up there called the
four leaf clover band so like the music
that you hear in the episode is actually
them like they did actually come and
like record music for that he said like
I saw that in the interview with him
so
so what they do is they decide they're
going to buy this house in Heritage Hill
which I've never been to Grand Rapids
Michigan but apparently this is like a
really really nice historic area
and if you buy a house there and
refurbish it you have to there's like
rules about it has to look like
historically accurate like from the time
period that it's from because they want
the neighborhood to look all over and
everything they want it to look like
that yeah
so uh yeah so they have to maintain them
in their original condition
so he buys the house and he's very
excited about it but uh his wife was
like yeah it needed a lot of work and
then she says our last house
um took nine years to renovate
so when she discovers that her husband
has bought yet another house that needs
extensive Renovations she's not really
all that jazzed about it she seemed she
was just like I just wanted somewhere
where we could like move in and like
actually
start living like a normal life instead
of just having to you know what I mean
it's just like which is understandable
because everywhere yeah like nine years
to renovate a house that's ridiculous
that you're like life would be upheaved
like that but she's just like I I don't
know I don't know about this but he's
like okay I promise that I will get all
of this renovation done in one year
now I'm not really sure because on the
show they showed that he did all of it
himself I kind of doubt that but I mean
you would think that he would have to
like hire people to come in it's like
how the [ __ ] would he have time because
he was working too like they said he
works part-time at his practice and then
like nights and weekends he would I was
like I don't know how much work this
house needed but one person doing all
that that would take longer than you I
don't think they showed the real house
or anything well no they never do they
never do me and not been that bad
well I don't know because she was
sitting there saying well one thing that
she said she said one it needed a lot of
work and two when he said I'll get it
done in a year she's like she was kind
of like no [ __ ] way so it was
obviously like pretty extensive but they
showed him doing all the work himself I
don't know if that's true or not but
that's what they showed on the show that
he said yeah I'll get it done in one
year I promise it'll be done because I
know I don't want to like you know have
your life upheavened and everything like
that
now pretty much okay so like the first
thing that kind of happens I guess a
week after they move in like he moves in
first like to work on the house and I
think they like live at the old place
for like a month or two or whatever
until like it's kind of like sorted out
so he's cleaning some [ __ ] out of the
basement and he's like the previous
owners whoever they were
um they left a bunch of stuff in there
and he's like they left like a you know
like a nice wooden workbench and like
some tools and all that kind of stuff so
he's like well I'm Gonna Keep some of
that stuff because it's nice and I might
need it or whatever but some of the [ __ ]
I'm gonna get rid of now he works he
says he works in the basement like
really really late like past midnight or
whatever and he said that he really felt
like someone was watching him I think
the the terminology that he used was
um there was a sensation that someone
was like hanging over you that's what he
said that's common yeah so that was like
the first thing and I kind of feel like
that's the first thing on a lot of these
shows it's like people feel like they're
being watched or they feel like there's
somebody in there like behind them or
some [ __ ] like that so he said that was
the first thing that he helped felt like
a heavy sensation like somebody hanging
over him like in the basement in
particular
so a couple months later uh the rest of
the family moves in once most of the
well not most of the renovation but some
of the renovations done now Sarah who at
the time that this happened did they say
what year this was I didn't write it
down
I mean the book he wrote the book in
2011 so I'm assuming that it was like
maybe a little bit before that I don't
think it but I don't think they
mentioned the year because usually
that's one of the first things I wrote I
write down but I guess they didn't
so the daughter Sarah now she was seven
years old now she was on the show too
but she was in Shadow even though her
mom and dad were interviewed and they
you could see their faces but she I
guess didn't want to be because maybe
she was still a teenager at this point I
don't really know so she's seven years
old and she's like all excited she said
oh my God it was this massive house it
looked like a castle blah blah now at
this point like all the major [ __ ] is
done it's mostly just kind of like minor
stuff that has to be done
so two nights after the family moves in
um Chris is up late and he's oh my God
what the [ __ ] does that say
got your glasses yeah I do but I can't
oh okay I remember that's like I can't
read my own handwriting well because I
was like writing so fast like because uh
you know and I was just like oh my god
what the [ __ ] I still don't know what
that says but I remember this scene so
now I remember so he's in there and he
has like um you know you put like the
big sheets of plastic like across the
opening or whatever and he has like the
tape you know so you can't so you don't
get like [ __ ] in the other room or
whatever
so he has that and it starts to kind of
like blow out like by itself like like
that even though there's no windows open
or anything and he said that he heard
like a breath or a gasp but he's like it
didn't sound like enough of a breath
that would like make the plastic like
Bell out like that and apparently like
it pulled the tape off as well even
though there was like no breeze so he
thought that was pretty weird too and
like I said he said he heard somebody
breathing or gasping that was that
um the next morning at breakfast this is
like pretty creepy so Patrick one of the
kids and he looked like the youngest one
like he was this little tiny boy
um he didn't come down like all the
other kids were down and like the mom is
just kind of like where's that other
[ __ ] kid like you know go up there
it's just she's calling him now he's up
there in his room and he looks over and
there's a dude like in a suit like
standing by his bedroom window
s surprisingly chill about the whole
situation oh man up there with his hair
slick back yeah I mean so basically
basically and she's like hey get up
there and get some breakfast or whatever
and he's like well you need to set
another place and she's like the [ __ ]
are you talking for your teddy bear or
whatever and she's like no for the man
in my room can you imagine if your kid
came and said that it's like yeah okay
let's make some pancakes for the man in
my room and be like oh she thought he
was making it up and he says yeah his
hair it goes back like that that was
like a pretty clue yeah and so yeah so
basically like yeah there's Amanda room
she's like okay whatever he's not
getting any pancakes I don't she didn't
say that
I'm saying so um so yeah see there's a
dude in a suit with his hair also I'll
slick back so there's that
um yeah and the mom said it was really
weird because he didn't seem scared like
when he said that when the kid said that
he just seemed like real matter of fact
like hey there's a man in my room watch
fix him some waffles or whatever
so then they jump ahead three months
um a lot of the stuff like the living
room seemed like it was done
and um which was kind of like a major
project I guess
so he so Chris like shows it to the rest
of the family and he's like ta-da you
know what I mean and then he's like I
need to go take a [ __ ] nap you know
what I mean because I've been working on
this [ __ ] like forever and I'm tired now
here's again where we get like the kind
of like dream reality thing like
blurring a little bit which like I said
I guess it's kind of cool the way they
did it
so he lays down to take a nap and he
while he's laying there he sees
um and it's actually kind of cool the
way they the way they shot it but it was
just kind of like they had all these
little framed pictures on the dresser
and they kept like moving around by
themselves like
like that like scooting around there
he's looking at him and he's like what
the [ __ ] because like that's what you
would do if they just started like
scooting around and he's just like
that's pretty [ __ ] weird and then
they then they're like oh just a dream
but he says when he woke up he's like
he's pretty sure that when he went to
take a nap it was like it seemed like it
was the middle of the afternoon or you
know it was still daylight out anyway
and he said when he woke up like
thinking that was real he said it was
like the middle of the night
so yeah I guess he kind of like just
slept all through the day and his wife
got in bed with him and he didn't like
wake up or nothing like that so he's
just like yeah I guess so which like I
said I've had that happen before too and
that's like that's very very
disorienting like if you put yeah you
fall asleep in the afternoon like at two
o'clock and then you wake up and you're
like what the [ __ ] it's dark outside
what day is it yeah who am I but yes
it's that kind of thing
um so he's like yeah I just had a really
weird dream but he doesn't tell her what
it is now the first stream was basically
just the little pictures going like that
and didn't like one of them break or
something I don't know something like
that it was just a dream yeah they were
like scooting around yeah but like I'm
saying well he saw that again like in a
later dream so they were kind of like uh
recurring is what I said now the same
night like I said it's not all dreams
because some of the other people in the
house like other family members to
experience some [ __ ] as well so
apparently later that same night like he
goes back to sleep his wife goes back to
sleep then his wife Kay wakes up and she
said that she felt a hand on her ankle
and like moving up her leg like it was
rubbing her leg
and he's all like was it a mouse and
she's like it wasn't like a mouse she's
like it didn't feel like crawling she
said it felt like a person like with a
hand on a leg like rubbing her leg and
it wasn't him so she was just like what
the [ __ ] was that all about so they're
like okay well who knows and then so
they just go back to sleep
now a couple nights after that uh Chris
is having trouble sleeping again like I
said it seemed like he's been plagued
with you know nightmares like since he's
been moving in here and he's laying
there and his kind of one eye is open or
whatever and he starts seeing he said I
start I start feeling something like
tapping or pushing on the pillow like
next to his head like he's laying on
here and then he's like he felt like a
finger like cushion like down on the
pillow and then they kind of show on the
show they kind of show it like pushing
down like like there was a head laying
down or something like that but he said
it felt like a finger like tapping or
pushing on the pillow and he's just kind
of like what the [ __ ] and he's like
looking at that but he doesn't tell Kay
though but then K is sleeping over here
and then the same thing happens on her
side of the bed like and I guess they
didn't tell each other like what was
going on so it like independently like
happened to both of them like somebody
like pushing on their pillows which is a
little bit creepy
so little [ __ ] like this seems to be
happening for the next couple weeks and
they're just like okay whatever so
they're just gonna like try and ignore
it right
um and then he has another thing or
another episode another dream with the
pictures moving like he's well the first
part of the dream is like the little
pictures moving like that and then like
the glass breaks
and then like he's standing in the
bedroom with his overalls on like the
overalls he's been you know working in
or whatever and an unseen Force like
picks him up off the floor but the
straps of the overalls and like pulls
him like toward the window and
essentially like throws him out the
window yeah now I don't know if they
showed this on the show but on the
interview that I read with him he said
that in the dream the window was closed
like it threw him through the glass
you know what I mean I don't know if the
window was open I don't remember the
last break or you go through it like
well that's what it was a dream so I'm
guessing he didn't say the glass broke
he just said the window was closed he
went through like he was a ghost yeah
but then like he woke up like before he
hit the ground
yeah so it like but it picked him up
like which I thought was kind of funny
but he said that he's like even though
he woke up and he was like what the [ __ ]
and like but he said that even though he
realized it was a dream he said It felt
really real like this was an actual
entity that was in the house that was
kind of like [ __ ] with him through
his dreams like that was something that
kind of like really happened sort of
yeah you know what I mean like he said
that was kind of the impression that he
got
so for the next month like over the next
month he keeps having basically like
dreams of his own death they don't
really show a lot of them and because I
got the impression like the way he was
talking about it that he just kept
having dreams where he kept dying in
different spectacular ways maybe that's
not true maybe he kept having the same
one but I kind of got the impression of
that and they only showed like one or
two like I said somebody throwing them
out the window there was one later where
he's like suffocated or whatever but
yeah so he just kept saying he's just
having dreams of his own death all the
time and it's like uh keeping him awake
as as it would so he's not really
getting much sleep but he said they seem
like they're really really real and that
there's something in this house that's
essentially like attacking him but like
through his dreams
um and he said whoever it is really does
not want me here that's why I was
talking about the dreams of the puppies
and [ __ ] yeah that was it I didn't I
didn't want to go to really tear the
house up looking for the puppies I
didn't have a feeling that there were
any puppies I just saw the things as a I
just saw the dreams as an attack
you know yeah something that it was
showing me you know to disturb you to
disturb you yeah but there may have been
something behind it but it wasn't
puppies
you know so you didn't think the puppies
were trying to contact you no save us no
you thought that it was like probably an
evil entity that was going look come
save these puppies but really let me out
of my the only thing that only thing
that I was worried about what it might
represent is children but I didn't I
wanted to kind of put that out of my
head
yeah I want to thank that along those
lines you know what I mean because
that's going a little too far well
that's kind of like I was kind of
thinking that maybe that's what it meant
but maybe it was meant to think that
though I care about that too yeah that
was the first thing that I jumped yeah
they may I may have been meant to think
that you know what I mean so just I just
tried to discount it as as just an
attack
Danny asked Tom when you were
experiencing Mammoth Mountain
Poltergeist did the Poltergeist affect
your dreams or your relatives dreams
no no I don't remember you saying
anything about that nope no but at the
other house yes
at the bad house that it was but yeah
not not a matter which you said that was
kind of like a different it was
different different experience
experience yeah I never really could
prove the the second the the bad house
it didn't move anything
but everyone could agree that it was a
bad house
it just didn't move anything we didn't
see any apparitions just emotional
attacks visions
dreams and Visions it's so kind of like
this like that kind of but he did see
some stuff they saw some apparitions
yeah well the kids did and the mom yeah
they they did have some things happen
like I said like the pillow thing the
pillow thing and like the the wife
having the feeling like a hand was on
her leg this is similar to the bad
houses just that the bad house was a lot
weaker than this if if his story is true
yeah but it sounds true this seems kind
of uh yeah kind of egregious sure a lot
of stuff going on for that kind of
Haunting I think it's a classic awning
yeah he seemed to perceive it as that
they they didn't really get and this
family are like seem very very religious
this was a Catholic Family
um but I I will give them credit that
they didn't jump to demon right they
just thought that it was uh a ghost who
was an [ __ ] who didn't want them in
the house like a dark entity they didn't
say demon they didn't say it was a part
of it they didn't really they did call a
priesthood to like to bless the [ __ ] but
it's like it wasn't really or no the
priest didn't even come there he goes to
the previous yeah we'll talk about that
it could be that
could be that or a part of a person kind
of like Mr Halloran says in the shinings
the you know sometimes places happened
and somebody's Left Behind like burnt
toast it's not there it's just pictures
in a book
just pictures just pictures anything
it's not real you're just sensing what's
happening right yeah yeah right how we
how creepy would it be if I woke up in
the middle of night and started doing
that to you
actually I don't want to give you any
ideas because you might do it and
that'll probably be but some places have
something kind of like shining and some
places do you know in Star Wars they'd
call it a place that was strong with the
dark side and it kind of has a will of
its own but I don't think that's what
this is
nightmares and rainbows says happy
birthday thank you very much
thank you very much so yeah so he's
perceiving that whatever this is it's
something that doesn't want him here and
is sending him these dreams it's like
hey I'm killing you in all these
creative ways you know what I mean now
then there's a scene so like I said
there's a kid one of the kids uh uh I
can't remember what the kid's name is
Andrew baby who's the older one and he's
in his room like practicing his guitar
and he said he started hearing somebody
clapping like in Rhythm like to what he
the music he was playing and it was
freaking about a little bit because it
was really nobody like everybody else
was downstairs and he said he just kind
of heard clapping so he goes down
and says to his parents like hey there's
some there's some like Spirit In My Room
[ __ ] clapping like in Rhythm and they
tried to like talk him out of it even
though they were very very well aware
he's in paranormal [ __ ] was going on but
they didn't really want to tell the kids
because they thought it would scare them
but the kids were apparently like seeing
stuff too so the kid comes down he's
like look I know clapping when I hear it
it sounded just like this and it's like
and obviously nobody was there and
they're just like oh maybe it's just the
house creaking or whatever just you know
knock it off
um so basically
so Chris at this point decides okay well
I'm gonna call a priest because like I
said this is like he was a very Catholic
Family
um and he's kind of like reluctant to
say anything because yeah you're gonna
go to the priest and say hey I think my
house is haunted like you know what I
mean he's just like a little bit
embarrassed about it I guess
um so the priest is this priest like
suck even more than the one that like
came to that one house and was just kind
of like bless bless bless and then it's
just like bye it's like I don't like it
in here like the door opened by itself
and he just runs out and they're like is
that it this priest didn't even get off
his fat ass and like wait was a skinny
ass he didn't get off his skinny ass and
go to the house he basically he goes to
the dude's office and the guy's like
well I don't really believe in those
kinds of things why don't you just go
home and pray I'm sure it's nothing and
he's just like well gee thanks for a big
fat nothing you know what I mean it's
like
don't let me like get get all up in your
molesting time or whatever the [ __ ] it
is you're doing here so yeah
let me get my uh things like Turn the
Page all right so uh so Chris and the
family are basically like okay well [ __ ]
that guy he didn't say that but I'm just
saying [ __ ] that guy
um we we're gonna we're on our own
so he starts doing
um you know the thing where he gets all
the books and all the stuff and he's
doing research you know what I mean
researching ghosts and demons at the
library
and then he goes and researches like the
city hall records now apparently this
house that they bought like I said it
was a historic house I don't think they
mentioned it was in Heritage Hill I
don't know um how old those houses are
generally in Grand Rapids Michigan
but um he said that previously this
house had only had three previous owners
however old it was so I'm guessing it
like stayed in the same families for a
long time
um and they find in all the old records
and stuff they find a picture that of
one of the previous like I guess it was
the owner before them or one before that
I'm not really sure like they didn't
really say like how long ago it was but
they find a picture of the guy and the
guy looks like the description that the
kids have been give like the kid gave it
like The Apparition guy that they that
he saw in his room
so they find out that the people that
lived there before them was a married
couple and they had lived there for 50
years now the husband had died 20 years
previously and then the Widow went to a
nursing home like and then hence they
sold the house
now I don't know like at the time that
this uh show was filmed it almost seemed
like they were saying like the Widow is
still alive but I don't they didn't like
go contact her so I don't really know
but she didn't die in the house
um the husband died in the house would
you stop it don't don't tear it up as
soon as she's in trouble
yeah she just jumped like yeah my my
foot hit the hit the leg of her chair
and she [ __ ] jumped oh she knows
daddy didn't mean it yeah she knows
don't tear up the books though the cats
whole [ __ ] reason for life is daddy
look at me daddy look at this
daddy look yeah Daddy look yeah she's
always doing that she's trying to get my
attention constantly yeah look and if
it's not you if like if you're sleeping
or something like that she comes in here
it's Mommy look Mommy yeah yeah Mommy
come here Mommy hey yeah it's like
having a kid it's just like a kid
a tiny little furry child yeah
but yeah so I guess the husband had died
in the house
but like I said the wife died in the
nursing home or it was still alive in
the nursing home I don't know they
didn't really specify
so at this point they're like okay well
since the priest isn't going to help us
like we know paranormal shit's going on
the kids are obviously seeing some
paranormal [ __ ] too and they're getting
a little like aggro that we're you know
denying the whole [ __ ] so it's like well
let's tell the kids we'll lay everything
out on the table because we'll be able
to fight this better whatever it is like
if we're all together as a family sir
you know so they finally tell the kids
and kids are like well duh yeah we've
been seeing like all this [ __ ] crazy
[ __ ]
uh you know we've been seeing several
months and months and we thought you
guys were like [ __ ] with us and not
telling us I'm I'm you know I'm making a
lot of this up so
a few like a little while later so Chris
is at a party at the neighbor's house
and the neighbors that were having the
party had a psychic there who was giving
free readings for you know like a party
trick or whatever
so he goes up to her and his friend kind
of like talks him into getting a free
reading and he's just like well you know
he says go easy on me I don't really
believe in this kind of stuff
and then she looks at him and she's like
are you she says something like are you
trying to restore the past or bring back
the past or something like that and she
seemed to know that he was restoring a
house and for a second I thought well if
this is in the same neighborhood as his
house I'm assuming that everybody that
buys a house there is like probably
restoring it so I don't think that's so
crazy that she would say that
um and she's like do you have something
from the house that I can like hang on
to
so he has a key and he gives it to her
because I guess she has that thing
what's that called what's that psychic
thing called where you hold something
yeah what the [ __ ] I know there's a word
for it I'll probably think of it in like
five five minutes from now but um yeah
so he gives her the key to hold on to
and she says
um yeah somebody who used to own it is
still there
and he his whole thing was well maybe
because he died in the house and his
wife
is either St is either still at the
nursing home or died at the nursing home
his theory was that the husband was like
still in the house because he was like
waiting for her like waiting for her to
die or wondering why she wasn't still in
the house that was his theory about why
the dude was still there
so he asks the psychic about that like
is that why like are you waiting for
your wife or something like that and
apparently the psychic got possessed and
got like scary possessive voice and she
says no I hate that woman and I was like
oh nice all right that ghost is a jerk
so that's cool
um so yeah he's not waiting for her
basically his whole thing is he just
likes the house and doesn't want to
[ __ ] leave yeah it's as simple as
that I mean that seems like that seemed
like his whole thing it's like it's my
house and I'm not leaving so [ __ ] off
um so yeah after that
um the dreams like get worse and worse
it says it got more violent more
frequent it said Sarah the daughter also
had trouble sleeping she said that a lot
of times they would hear [ __ ] like
footsteps coming up the stairs like
their doorknobs would Rattle and all
that kind of stuff
um Sarah also said she saw the same dude
like The Apparition like she and I got
the impression that she had seen him
more than once because like she's laying
there in bed and like kind of peeks over
and like he's just [ __ ] standing
there like in the doorway of her room
like staring at her being all creepy and
she's just kind of like well there he is
again that's kind of like that's a
little disturbing but yeah so there's
that
um so yeah and like I said the ghost is
the same like the the description is the
of the um ghost that apparently like
Chris has been seen in his dream
so uh so then we have another thing
where Chris is in the basement again
and the light bulb starts unscrewing
itself yeah I forgot about that one he
saw it moving yeah he said he saw it
moving and then
um but like I said I don't know if this
really happened or if this is a dream
Jesus the light bulb starts unscrewing
itself and then
um he goes over to like there's a big
cabinet down there which I'm assuming
the other owners left yeah and he's like
I knew something was like going on with
that cabinet it was like a big wardrobe
or something it kind of looked like a
big wardrobe and so he goes over there
and opens it and then like a big like
black shadow comes out of it and like
starts suffocating him and he said that
was like the worst dream that he had
because that was okay so the whole thing
was a dream yeah yeah I think the whole
thing I think the whole thing with the
light bulb I think that was a dream too
but like I said that's what I meant they
come we're kind of like blurring the
line I don't know if he was actually in
the basement and saw that happen no or
he later on he's saying that he keep he
kept having sidekick dreams paranormal
dreams is what he called him yeah which
their messages
same thing happened yeah
it's just putting ideas in his head
trying to tell him something
so he said that was like the worst one
because it almost seemed like like it
looked like I couldn't really tell what
it was it was just kind of like this
black cloudy thing and it came out of
this wardrobe I think they're just
trying to express it was just a and it
was just like a son of a crazy mass of a
[ __ ] bad energy which that was in
that house in that bad house too there's
no way to describe it it's like
something just bearing down on you yeah
you know and you can't see anything
there's nothing there you feel like a
fool and you try to run out of it
and you feel like you did run out of it
and then you'd have a feeling that it
was behind you and you'd be looking at
it and it wouldn't just be you you know
I mean my buddy Eric would same thing
girlfriends that would come over you had
to walk them to the bathroom and guard
them while they were in there you know
it was it was a real phenomenon but
nothing you could measure or photograph
you couldn't prove it people would say
it's your imagination
powerful ass imagination that [ __ ]
affect everybody that went into the
house it was just a bad feelings in the
house Zach said maybe we should write a
book about that house wouldn't be much
to the book
that'd be a thing
and I can't prove any of it that's true
I know where the house is
I can find it again
well um how long were you living there
about a year about a year and a half
yeah I was gonna say I didn't remember
like it being that long
all right so where was I okay so yeah so
the thing comes out
of the Wardrobe and like seems like it's
suffocating him and he said that was
like the worst one it seems like he woke
up
sitting on the couch it was like holy
[ __ ] that's like the worst [ __ ] dream
ever
so a week later they have a couple of
friends over like for drinks
and uh Kay who is over this [ __ ] and
like Chris says that Kay actually
normally like 99 of the time kept her
[ __ ] together so the fact that when they
had friends over for Drake said she had
a couple cocktails and she just started
like having a nervous breakdown like
basically like yeah I can't take this
[ __ ] anymore he's like so that was like
really really unusual because normally
she would like I said keep her [ __ ]
together but she couldn't do it anymore
so um she basically is like the shit's
haunted um I don't know what to do about
it
and she said that she had been in the
basement earlier that day and I guess
this is what kind of like spurred her to
actually like kind of just you know have
a breakdown about it was that she was in
the basement and she saw
I wasn't clear over whether she actually
saw this literally or whether
it was kind of like an impression that
she got you know what I mean because
it's almost kind of like she said Vision
but then she said she felt it so I don't
know she actually like saw it with her
eyeballs or if it was just something
that was like kind of projected into her
mind or something I don't know but what
they showed on there she said that
she saw a little girl and that there was
some kind of like violence perpetrated
on the little girl and so she's
extrapolating that maybe this [ __ ]
that used to live here
um that's still haunting them maybe yeah
maybe like beat up a a little girl or
something like that and they were trying
to say he was he was a he was a Peter
that's yeah I kind of feel like that's
Maplewood there but they don't like they
don't go anywhere with that like that's
pretty much the only mention of it like
the only time anybody saw like a child
getting beat up it's like she saw it so
she's basically like okay well the guy
that used to live here was like like I
said like an abusive pedo so there's
that so uh their friends are basically
like okay well um if you've already gone
to the priest and he hasn't done [ __ ]
all then maybe it was like we have a
friend who's like a spiritual healer
it's like she doesn't usually do this
kind of [ __ ] like she's not like a
Paranormal Investigator or anything
um and she doesn't usually do the whole
like saging saging the [ __ ] or whatever
but it's like I'll give her a call and
she'll come over and maybe she'll be
able to do something about it like we'll
see
so uh so the spiritual healer lady comes
over I think she was actually on the
show like her and her husband like work
together I don't think the husband I
don't remember the husband being on the
show but she definitely was
um and she's like she walks in and she's
like oh you've renovated the place and
he's like well yeah um and she's like
yeah well you know go some like that
like you know they that stir [ __ ] up
um and she's like uh she was like
attracted right to the basement she's
like yeah some [ __ ] up [ __ ] happened
down here although they didn't specify
like what it was or if she said exactly
what it was
um and she pretty much at least
according to their accounts that when
she went down to the basement and saw
that wardrobe thingy
um she was pretty much that's where the
energy is coming from like this cupboard
or wardrobe that Chris had had the dream
about like that the suffocating [ __ ] was
coming out of so so apparently she went
down and so I was and I'm sitting there
going man like even if you were some
like [ __ ] ghost or something like
that you got like the whole house to run
around and why would you like sleep in a
closet I don't know
or another cupboard but she said that's
where the um that's where the energy was
coming all the negative energy yeah he
was centered and so they go and open it
and then I kind of I hate to laugh but
it will no I don't but um that's not
true oh yeah oh yeah and it's like their
feet their feet are sliding and stuff
like that I was just like oh my God all
the nothing it's just kind of like yeah
so it's I don't know it's just a CG
black cloud the way they shot it was
funny yeah you know what I mean then I
just kind of laughed and I was like
they're getting pushed I know what
they're talking about I know I know but
it's just like it was funny the way they
talk about that weird oppressive feeling
that [ __ ] that there's something
there that was in the closet yeah
oh
black frog has just arrived saying hello
hello how are you doing
um so yeah well I think it wasn't so
even so much funny that like them just
being like Oh no like this force is
coming out of the thing because when
they did this part I don't even think
they showed like the black cloud coming
out of there I think I don't remember if
they did because I know they did when he
was having the nightmare about it yeah
but I think the reason why I laughed is
because they didn't maybe they forgot to
CGI that in for this so now you just
have like these two people just going ah
like there's like nothing there and then
maybe like maybe I never remember I
think I think it was there maybe well
like I said I was kind of trying to look
at I was looking up and down because I
was sick they were trying to play camera
tricks because they didn't want you to
see their feet doing this as they were
backing up yeah they're trying to get at
the angle right to like like they were
being repelled by a an evil force when
they open and then they were pushing
back which is which was even funnier
yeah like for some reason that was even
they're using their mom skills [ __ ]
from drama class
yeah I'm in a glass box yeah
that's it no absolutely it's show
business no shade on the actors I'm no
shade on the actors yeah y'all are good
y'all do what you got to do everybody
Gotta Eat you know what I mean still a
good episode it is it's like funny I I
make jokes because I love okay I'm not
I mean I kind of feel like I kind of
feel like you get kind of like upset
when I make jokes about it and it's like
I'm making jokes because I like them I
just like you know what I mean that was
just like really really funny to me I
don't really know what happened in real
life I wasn't there unless they opened
it up and got a bad feeling in there
like oh that's what I'm saying I kind of
feel like yeah that's what happened
that's what I that's what I mean well
because I'm always kind of like my mind
is always like in real life what did
that look like probably like nothing
like nothing they just opened a thing
and we're like no I don't like it you
know it does it smells like mothballs in
there yeah but yeah so I kind of feel
like that so I don't think they were
going like oh no
get back in there you [ __ ] that
wouldn't have looked real that's what
I'm saying so they always have to like
over dramatize everything so I'm like
I'm sure in real life well it's just
kind of like you know how on every
single episode where they do like a big
climactic
um you know exorcism or whatever healing
or whatever at the end and it's always
they always kind of show like they do
like all those really quick cuts and
like flashing lights and it's like all
those crazy camera angles but it's like
if you were really there in real life
it'd just be everybody stand around
waving Sage around like that yeah and
like nothing happening
um
in in the episode
the The Little Ghost Hunters what were
they they weren't Ghost Hunters wouldn't
be a good winner she said she was they
said she was a spiritual healer the
spiritual and like I said they she said
that they don't that she didn't usually
do that kind of yeah that she didn't
usually go around like cleansing
people's houses my opinion in my opinion
if you're having problems like this in
your house that you don't even mess with
those people they'll make it worse
because they'll come up with their own
explanations that might be wrong and
they're just going to add to your
[ __ ] stress you know you're better to
get hold of [ __ ] a pair of
psychologists somebody who knows what
they're doing all right who knows but
anyway that's that's lectured but anyway
probably
one of the things that they said was
funny is they said well he's in this
cabinet he's living in this cabinet that
that's not what's happening all right a
ghost in the closet yeah that's not
what's happening freaking it's going to
be kind of like like I said I like to
use I like to use well-known
rioters like
you know [ __ ] Stephen King because he
actually did do homework and studied the
works of parapsychologists and people up
at UCLA and everything and so he was he
was very astute in his day and I liked
what his character Mr Howard would say
is it's going to be
it's like pictures in a book it's like
burnt toast something's left behind
and in this case it's centered around
that
cabinet
so some somebody associated with that
had an association with that cabinet
that's bad
and that's kind of where
that's kind of where it kind of
partially emanates from
you know because whatever this person
was whatever they were doing when they
were alive there was a connection with
that cabinet as long as that cabinet's
there you're going to have a piece of
that person kind of like
the smell of burnt toast maybe that guy
maybe that guy
um locks the little girl in the in the
closet could have been anything could
have been he might have had a bunch of
collector's item stuff that was it that
was that he stored in there before he
got rid of it or before his wife threw
it out or something might have been a
bunch of porn in there you don't know
but for some reason it was something
that part of him wanted to guard or a
part of him okay
well I don't think he's guarding it I
don't think he's guarding it no I'm just
it's just a kind of like a remnant of a
certain aspect of the dude's energy
piece of the dude's Soul Left Behind
like burnt toast
something like that his connection to
that area
and other people can pick it up and part
and part of it has a life of its own
showing your pictures in a book
trying to communicate with you but I
don't think it's a full person if here's
here's why if you ever if you've had an
out of body experience or a near-death
experience
and if you did that in that house to try
to see what that was and that'd be the
way to do it
you're not probably not gonna find a
full Soul you're gonna find a [ __ ]
collection of memories of somebody who's
long gone it's gonna be that something
like that
it might be a life form but not a full
one
because you know they're not
they're not organic they're energy
if you chop a person's hand off the hand
dies if you if a person throws a certain
part of their soul out that thing might
live on
you know maybe they throw a part of the
bad part of themselves out to kind of
purge it and then they move on leaving
that bad part behind well it's Life
Energy kind of like the thing
that thinks in another dimension [ __ ]
with limited understanding and limited
skills made up of [ __ ] something bad
and it's just continuing to to exist in
a slightly different dimension and it's
not a full being
that's that's that matches up with
certain things that I saw during that
out of body experience it's gonna be
something like that
because
if you ever exterior eyes
you kind of have an understanding of
kind of like Cosmic Consciousness and
you start to have access to things that
you didn't even see at the time but you
kind of
kind of aware of their existence and
then when you come back a lot some of
it's for God you don't quite remember it
the same way reality isn't the same once
you're out but that's whatever that is
it's something like that
I forgot this actually kind of this this
actually gets funnier because not only
are they just pushing it like back in
the closet they're actually pushing it
outside they pushed it like yeah yeah
yeah out the window it's just like don't
spoil it like it's funny yeah so um so
the spiritual advisor is basically like
okay we pushed it outside so now it's
outside I'm like thanks [ __ ] now it's
gonna go haunt the neighbor's house or
whatever
um but anyway she's like I would advise
that anything that still that belongs to
that dude because remember I said at the
beginning that he kept his workbench and
his tools and stuff she's like yeah
throw all that [ __ ] out because it's
maybe it's like kind of keeping him here
so he's like Okay can do so he's just
like [ __ ] he's like yeah I'm gonna
get rid of all this [ __ ] because I think
the workbench like the dude had built it
or whatever so then they go out and they
do like a perimeter around the house
with water and salt in her herbs herbs
yeah because there's a [ __ ] H in it
uh Eddie is there
um and stuff now K is the one that has
to do it because according to the
spiritual healer lady women create and
hold space
yeah all right just how they do it now
um I don't know know I don't believe
none of that I think everybody's about
the same but see how I'm doing that yeah
create new hope you can't do that yeah
only woman can do that
Danny's Daddy's asking he says you
remember the pictures and Scatman
Crothers room one of those exists
somewhere those pictures were common
back in the uh early 80s yeah I remember
seeing like other people they're real
they're real popular with black dudes
and it was just a series of paintings I
don't know if they were on Black Velvet
or not I don't maybe they weren't I feel
like they probably should be even if
they even if they weren't but they were
very pretty decent
I would call them sensual
African-American nudes they all had the
[ __ ] damn
bad ass bodies and big [ __ ] afros it
was like something out of the 70s they
were real popular
we had guys buying them they're around
somewhere you can find those
although that one that was in scatman's
room if you got a copy of that one
imagine the original you can't get it
but the copy probably cost you a lot of
money because it would be famous from
that movie yeah but that was just one of
them some of them had a man and a woman
like in Embraces that's the one that I
remember because I remember saying whose
house was I at that I saw them I don't
know I mean I was a kid it was all
African-American art oh it must have
been my Dad's friend yeah I think I was
at my dad's friend's house and he had
that
um yeah so women are creating and
holding space like like we're doing see
how I'm doing right here like live on TV
on YouTube so they made like a spirit
wall
um and here's the funny thing so the guy
like he throws all the stuff like Chris
throws all the dudes [ __ ] out and he was
like real excited about too he's like
man I'm not he's not even just gonna
like
throw away the workbench he's gonna like
chop it all up and he's just like
putting the stuff in the in the garbage
can like a man and then like we're
watching it we're like yeah go haunt The
Dump you better
I was like there's any side of the ghost
to the dump that's where he's gonna go
with all his [ __ ] stuff so uh so yeah
so the kids come back because I guess
they sent them away while they were
doing the [ __ ] and then they do the
whole positive love like Kumbaya
whatever and uh apparently it works they
push the ghosts outside no they didn't I
will note that they apparently didn't
get rid of the ghost they just pushed
him outside the house and they will let
him back in I guess because they made
like this whole like Spirit wall like
around there so we can't get back in
so uh it all worked yay uh they said you
could tell right away
now here's the funny bit four weeks
later says Chris he's out in the
neighborhood jogging
and he's jogged and he looks over in the
Shrubbery like in the woods or something
like that and he sees the [ __ ] ghost
over there yeah in the neighborhood he
said it was I don't know how far it was
away he's out in the bushes he said it
was a few blocks away yeah and the dude
was like looking at him and I'm like you
locked him out of his house he's running
it'd be something I've never heard that
before you're running down the street
you look out in the woods and the ghost
is out there looking at you [ __ ] you
got my house and I was like oh my God
I'm just living out here in the woods
you feel bad do you feel bad that was my
house [ __ ] but yeah
so he didn't go haunt The Dump he just
went and wanted like a couple blocks I
don't know it was a few blocks away but
I just thought that was like that really
like made me laugh to you then like the
the ghost would go like haunt the
neighborhood he's like outside he's all
like sure wish I could go haunt somebody
else's house but nobody else wants me to
come and eat he could just go haunt
somebody else's house I would think they
could just do whatever they want
um so basically so what they have to
keep doing he says I guess to keep the
ghost out and to keep his sad little ass
like over there like a few blocks away
so he can't get back in so they have to
keep doing this little like Spirit wall
hey keep out ghost ritual and apparently
they have to do it every night and he's
like so the whole family oh my God thank
you Deborah damn looks like a big old
holy [ __ ] what is that 50. thank you
very much thank you oh that that reminds
me our UK uh Patriot Patron Dermot also
sent me fifty dollars oh great thank you
for my birthday thank you very much I
meant to say that at the beginning of
the show and I completely forgot about
it thank you about that uh yeah thank
you very much that's so awesome happy
birthday Jim thank you I know I'm having
a good one having a good one but yeah so
yeah so they're doing all this
and eventually the family gets sick of
doing it as you would
Chris is kind of like sick here he's
like no we have to keep doing it he's
like well I'll just do it by myself that
they're just like Jesus Christ like
every single night we have to do this
it's like no thank you which I get it uh
so Chris sort of does it by himself so
he's doing the thing at the cabinet and
because you think everything's over now
she's doing the thing at the cabinet and
then he
is he slips into a dream world or is the
whole thing a dream I'm not really sure
but he's in the dream and he starts
fighting The Ghost and he legitimately
punches and goes because remember on the
other show we did that from a dream
right but remember how on the other show
like the guy was saying he's like you
don't know what to do about a ghost you
can't punch it
um but apparently if you're in a dream
you can punch it like it does because he
because Chris in this episode does
actually punch it it makes sense
although it's in a dream he punches
you're in a dream or and it's in a dream
with you you could because it's
psychological warfare nobody's hurt it's
just it's just ideas
well it's kind of like that in the in in
the uh in the spirit world too you can't
really destroy anything
it's just not really your place to
destroy anything you can just drive
things off uh it's just images imagery
information
so that's that's what he did
he was in a dream and it started
fighting it in the dream and it had an
effect yeah
wouldn't destroy it though
you can just punch it you can punch it
just make it mad or make it matter hurt
it or Scare
I kept out of this homeless ghosts my
life in the bush of ghosts
I don't know
pickles me so much I just thought that
was so funny
um so so yeah so either in the dream or
in the real world I'm not entire dream
but well yeah but then he had the whole
thing where he brought the little stool
and the Bible or whatever the [ __ ] and
he sat in front of the cabin that was
later that's what I'm saying yeah well
it was like it was only like a minute
later in the real world in the real
world he basically does kind of like a
Buddhist or almost kind of like a
Buddhist or Taoist exorcism
aesthetic he says I can't make it leave
I can't force it to leave which he's
learned he learned that from that fight
because I just told you what he learned
that from that fight in that dream you
can't destroy it
so he went down and counseled it and
talked it over to the [ __ ] over over
the other side which is plausible
it's plausible he he kind of he
counseled it he said his quote was I
loved him out yeah
which sounds a little weird but okay
but like I said he is yeah punching it
it won't work it didn't really work I'm
sure you can't force it to leave so you
kind of have to solve its problems so it
leaves on its own that's what he did
which uh no that matches up but that
would probably work yeah
Danny Rowling said he just Lucid dreamed
and fought the ghost
yeah
Maybe
they were paranormal dreams
interesting connection between him and
whatever Remnant that was
interestingly I was reading like I said
an interview with this guy like shortly
before shortly after this episode came
out because like I said he had written a
book called trespass about this case
like before the episode came out
and he said that you know the scene
where uh in the show where K goes down
to the basement and says that she saw
like the whole pedo episode yeah
apparently
um he said that something worse happened
to his wife down there but he didn't say
what it was and he said they didn't want
to put it on the show okay
so I don't really know came after what
he's getting at yeah but apparently
whatever it was they didn't really want
to put it on them it could grab you
evidently well she said that she felt
like a hand on her leg Yeah at some
point and then she said that it was
pushed and it was good pushing all the
pillows on the pill so you know he was
[ __ ] with him all the time
that ghost is a [ __ ] yeah do you hear
that ghost you're a [ __ ] person yeah
like whatever you were doing but yeah
there was uh
one of those cases I've been a long time
I saw it on Geraldo this is a [ __ ]
long time ago I think it was Geraldo
and had a Paranormal Investigator and he
was just going on about a bunch of other
cases and he had three or four women on
there
I don't know if it's the snedekers I
don't think it was the snedekers they
were renting some
house sharing it
and um
weird kind of sexual things would happen
that one girl said that she woke up in
the middle of the night
and heard a man grunting and [ __ ]
looked at the foot of the bed and
kneeling on the floor
she didn't quite say it the way I'm
gonna say it but kneeling on the floor
at the foot of the bed but some old dude
[ __ ] just just beating it just
working it over [ __ ] staring at her
choking the chicken yeah and she
screamed and he vanished and like
dissipated strangling the bishop
whatever you want to call it
and there was stuff like that happening
and it was young women teenage girls and
young women 20s and stuff and a few of
the older ones but they were all cute
attractive and they all had to guard
each other when they were taking the
showers because they'd be grabbing them
in the shower so they could take showers
by themselves
and um they uh
the Paranormal Investigator says based
on all the descriptions of who the dude
is he knew who he was
you didn't mention any names but he says
it was the uh
he said it was the um not the caretaker
but what do you call it kind of like the
landlord's character yeah the landlord's
caretaker of the little yeah caretaker
yeah yeah manager or something yeah I
like the like the property manager that
took care of that
it was a it was a group of houses and he
said that was him
and they said the description fits
perfectly
and that was the last time I heard that
case it was a long time ago [ __ ]
creepo yeah bad enough they do that [ __ ]
when they're alive and then after
they're dead they still like linger he
hadn't been dead that long like four or
five years well he needs to [ __ ] off to
wherever it is yeah he's in some damn
bar at least part of him in some kind of
damn
Perpetual or Perpetual Peep and Tom
[ __ ] status it's like ooh part of me
survived death I'm gonna just jerk off
the whole time
aim high evidently he kind of had a
reputation for [ __ ] like that when he
was alive drilling holes and walls and
stuff
are suspected of that kind of sounds
about right yeah
Brian hackett's here happy birthday
Jenny thank you I'm on another feature
started today but hopefully you have a
great day thank you very much hi Tom
Ryan hack it's a buddy of mine who went
to military school together his kids
he's been he's done a lot of a lot of
movies did Terror in the prairie did the
[ __ ] what's that what about concrete
um [ __ ] we saw a couple of other movies
I don't remember them all
he'll remind me black frog said we need
Chris Hansen to go ghostbusting right
yeah yeah
well in in a really bad case
it's gonna the perpetrator is gonna be
something like that
some of these people will come across
with ideas like demons and [ __ ] like
that that's very unlikely
there are people we've talked about them
on the show they've done things that
[ __ ] you wouldn't think a human could
do like stick damn ice picks through
girls [ __ ] ears and
pull pieces of them off with down pliers
and stuff like that you know just for
fun and uh you would think to yourself
man no human could do that and you're
right they're not really humans I would
never treat a dude like that as a human
I would treat a dude like that as a
mutant all right and law enforcement is
around
to keep me from doing something bad to a
dude like that if I came across them if
I came across some dude like that that'd
be it
I'd really have to I'm lucky I've never
come across anything like that because
I'd be [ __ ] put into a really
terrible conundrum because I just would
not want to let that opportunity slip
between my fingers to just [ __ ] do to
like that up you know I'd have to be
sure but I would just [ __ ] that dude up
I mean if you're really sure I would
probably I caught a dude in the ACT
that's it you're [ __ ] over
you know
I don't know I kind of feel like I'm
just gonna start cutting little pieces
of you off and I'm gonna put them in a
stew and eat them in front of you I'm
gonna do all kind of [ __ ] when I see
that kind of virus and I see that kind
of violence it almost brings it out of
me you know
like it makes you understand why Prince
Vlad tepesh you know [ __ ] Prince you
know also Vlad Draco why he was impaling
people and stuff I imagine you know you
know if you see enough of it you just
get very mean and very insensitive and
you just really start to hate your
enemies you start doing stuff like that
and it's a bunch of Tit for Tat stuff
that builds up and me hearing about
seeing some of these serial killer cases
and [ __ ] reading the details and [ __ ]
just like I've read some details of
[ __ ] some [ __ ] that was done to
animals that said man I couldn't let you
just walk around after you're doing that
to a damn dog yeah I just couldn't let a
[ __ ] walk around like that and
I've killed a bunch of animals and honey
hunting but it's all food it's
professional it's not to maximize the
[ __ ] suffering of animals you know
the psychological ammos you know it's
like a terrible
making mom and dogs eat their own babies
and [ __ ] like that [ __ ] yeah I'd
[ __ ] killed it like dude I can't even
kill a moth for Christ's sake I can't
even imagine like what kind of monster
you would have to be so some of these
paranormal cases you know that they say
well it's demons no very unlikely a
demon if you look at the actual
definition and many definitions are
given if you're going to use the Bible
as
as a basis to to define it
it says about three different things
okay it calls them all demons
that demon is
one of God's sons that was thrown out of
heaven and in chained for creating the
Nephilim by screwing the women that's in
[ __ ] Genesis
and later on knock it off Netflix yeah
yeah
Giants and they're talking about
demigods
you know my Hercules and [ __ ] Samson
another thing that they would call a
demon is the spirits of the Evil Dead
you know Jesus throws a whole bunch of
them out of pit out of a man and throws
him into a herd of pigs and they jump
off the that's not the same that's not
Angels that's the Evil Dead
can also be a demon so there's at least
two things that they're talking about
they're not the same
and the diff the the difference between
those stories they're the time between
the stories that are written was a long
time so
whoever wrote these stories they weren't
sure what a demi was either
it was just something bad something
invisible you couldn't see it
well yeah like we've talked about this
before it's like fanfic everybody just
kind of like added their own [ __ ] on
there yeah so none of it's real Canon
because they've got a lot of a lot of it
like contradiction yeah in Islam they
have something called The Gin
the gin's kind of like a demon
but not really
it says that some of the Gin spend their
time herding flocks and they're [ __ ] in
their in the dimension that they live in
and handling their business and they can
be Islamic gym gym business yeah gin
business
Christian gin and Jewish gin and just be
of any religion
and some of them you can deal with and
some of them you can't
so really
the Islamic description of a gin does
not really
the Christian description doesn't fit
the Christian definition of a
of a demon a gin
more closely resembles what westerners
would call uh people in purgatory
waiting for final judgment they're in
purgatory in an afterlife in kind of
their own virtual reality bubble doing
their normal lives waiting for judgment
some of them if they're converting to
religions they're heard and sheep buying
houses so they're in a dreamlike world
okay they're in the metaverse they're
like a metaverse that's what they're
talking about and then maybe you can get
the attention of one of these gin and
get it to do things
that's kind of like talking to the Dead
you know even though I think that I
think the the Quran claims that they
never lived
but how would they really know you know
you might
make the mistake of thinking that the
thing had never lived
I think they might be mixing several
stories together
because Jen definitely predate Islam
that goes back before Islam that's
that's Arabic culture not so much
religious culture other Arabic religions
have those
Danny said Rosemary Ellen giley talked a
lot about the Jane very fascinating
stuff I never read that I've read a lot
of her books actually but um I don't
think I've read that one she did like
ones about vampires and were werewolves
and all that kind of stuff too stole
into like folklore and whatnot but I've
read a bunch of her books but I haven't
read the Gen one
I uh worked with a guy from Iraq
after I got out of the army I told him
about the Poltergeist and he was [ __ ]
he took that the Mammoth Mountain told
the whole story how it went
and he goes that was a gin and I said
yeah he goes yeah he explained to go to
gym was the first time I've ever heard
of a jib Islam had its own ex
explanation but his interpretation was
that it was a gin which made me think
well stories of the Gin would have been
bolstered by Poltergeist Poltergeist and
ghosts if you saw a ghost or a
poltergeist
you're in the Middle East you're going
to say it's a gin but I believe they
have ghosts too
I believe
well I should say that when we were in
the restaurant today yeah um oh hey can
neck yay we made it happy uh Happy Jenny
day y'all happy birthday Jenny world is
happy that you made it another year oh
thank you very much that's very nice of
you
um but yeah so when we were in the
restaurant today the magical meat
Boutique
um Elaine told us that now did she say
it was this it was this place or the old
restaurant okay so apparently the
location where they are now
um is not where they were like they
moved from another location like an
older building it was a couple years ago
a couple years ago so she said at the
old location she was in there she had
just opened the restaurant I think she
said and it was like really early in the
morning
and she said one of the glasses the wine
glass like a wine glass that was hanging
like in the rack like on the on the uh
above the bar she said that it flew off
like suddenly and like smashed into a
like a wall or a or no something like
that or just like said it flew out about
seven feet and then broke and then broke
so all of a sudden said no one threw it
and she because she was sitting there
going man like she's like I don't really
believe in ghosts or nothing like that
but she was like I was just kind of like
holy [ __ ] and well she said at the old
place too because she kept telling us
when we told her about the show I got
that I got that on tape her saying that
tell him a story yeah I'll have to like
I said I gotta check that it's on my
phone somewhere if we'll see how much of
it got on yeah she's wow yeah she was
like funny as hell but um but yeah she
was talking about uh she said yeah at
the old place I don't think she saw it
but she said one of the other employees
um she said at the old place she's like
somebody came in or they were gonna
close or no it was like really early in
the morning she said it was like five
o'clock in the morning and somebody had
come in and they said they saw a guy
walk through the place and like go in
the bath
and they're like so they go in they're
like hey bro we're like not open yet and
they went to the bathroom and there was
nobody in there so yeah so she's like
the old place because she told us oh you
guys should go like do an investigation
over there because that's the place that
this restaurant used to be at and she's
like that's shit's super haunted now she
did say did she say that the building
that we're in now is on it I think well
I don't think she's seen anything yeah
but she said like the glass being like
thrown and stuff like that was she says
the whole area is supposed to be is
rumored to be here it's Mount Dora by
the way it's the historic district of
Mount Dora which like I said I think
this is that's maybe like the only
second time in my life I've only been
down I've ever been down there but
there's some cool [ __ ] down there yeah I
was like man that's only like 10 miles
away I should go down there and like
poke around because man I don't know why
I'm coughing yeah you're having all kind
of problems
I don't feel sick
feel like I was smoking cigarettes hmm
what I want I don't know
okay so Danny says what's btk's opinion
on gin
I want a gin oh wow you know everybody
knows it it's Islam
if it was true it'd be in the Bible
I kind of feel like that's probably
exactly what he was of course yeah yeah
yeah I like that he a little I don't
know if you guys know but the little BTK
that's back there in one of his hands he
has a little cross yeah yeah he's
religious he was very religious or
wanted to repeat religious well that's
how they busted him was uh from because
he was sending like his weird letters
like or saving the [ __ ] like on the um
on the disc like at the church he was
having necro necrophiliac photo shoots
with uh
um beautiful grannies
um in in the church laying them out in a
church taking pictures of him that's
right that one woman that was and she
lived like down the street from him
right yeah he was doing a whole
pantyhose fetish and everything what the
[ __ ] bro seriously like read that book
like I think it's called like Sophie
sent it to me right I think it's just
called Confessions of a serial killer
that's all about BTK and it's all about
her correspondence because she
corresponded with this [ __ ] freak for
years and years like the [ __ ] his
thought processes just blew my [ __ ]
mind
I was just yeah I can't even explain it
I was just like is this dude even like
what is the matter with you literally
the thing that gets me is like uh
I guess you could say how kind of
masculine he wanted to appear you know
like he's [ __ ] tough guy you know
even though he's a dog catcher and just
nothing wrong with that it's just he
wanted to measure her yeah he wanted to
be a cop you know
and uh he wouldn't cut out for a cop
he's just not the right personality and
the um
he was doing stuff like putting on going
out into the woods and digging Graves
and setting up a camera and putting on
women's
underwear and putting on a woman's mask
and getting down in there and taking
pictures of himself somehow I guess he
pulled the camera was there a string on
the camera
and he was taking pictures of himself in
the grave yeah that might have been or
no I think it had a timer on it timer
okay he was just a [ __ ] trip and I
don't know how he got all that [ __ ]
developed I guess he developed it
himself
oh I don't remember if he said yeah
because it's not yeah back in the old
days you had to like take the [ __ ] to be
yeah after the photo man people be
looking at your [ __ ] photos before
you got them so sorry I just thought see
remember how I said the other day that
sometimes y'all took a copy in her
photos sometimes I just think of like
random uh quotes from movies I just
thought of woo it's more of the redhead
with the tattoo yeah I like the two kids
that worked in the photo I think that
was always rumors that those dudes were
copying films I'm sure they did if they
were good ones because like I said
unless you had a Polaroid I mean get a
[ __ ] Polaroid if you're gonna take
[ __ ] they took shitty pictures back
then well I know they did I know it's
easy to develop get developing Solutions
and a [ __ ] magnifier and a down yeah
I learned how to do it in school
that'd be the way to do it
it's a pain in the ass yeah but if
you're if you're really committed yeah
to it's not being expensive I'm not
encouraging it it's not that no I'm just
like not if you're a serial killer
obviously but if you want to do your own
porn like nowadays like this digital now
that's what I mean like nowadays that's
a moot point because you don't need to
do that [ __ ] nowadays
um Zach says I like how you call it the
historic district of Mount Dora like
that's its actual name it's well it's
not his actual name but it's I mean the
town's name is Mount Dora but not all of
it is historic yeah like some of it's
just like looks like regular but took
the tour Series yeah like the old part
like is just kind of like this little
really and it's all like little museums
and little antique shops and cool little
bars and coffee shops and [ __ ] like that
it's pretty cool people people [ __ ]
forget that Florida is older than the
United States
all right this is older than the United
States it goes back well yeah like I
said I think I said that about like
Mount like the whole historic thing like
on the Lakeside in Mount Dora is not
I don't know what what year they built
that but I mean it's not as old as like
Saint Augustine which is like [ __ ] 14
13 something which is no 1500. some of
that was from 1500s or 1600s
um not all of it obviously like not all
the houses around there but I mean it's
pretty like a lot yeah you go down Mount
Dora the churches look uh like Spanish
Spanish churches and
just this kind of Spanish Empire looking
stuff
but the Spanish right here the British
were here
Seminoles I think the Dutch were here
too everybody French everybody was
tramped all over this place yeah
um hands too who owned what and they
would fight over stuff
I'm revonne vampire says happy birthday
Jenny thank you I always love to watch
your haunting shows yeah shamey got here
like after we were done talking about
the show but oh well well it's still
there like you can like watch it Danny
Rowling said uh it's crazy how most
serial killers were ex-military yeah a
lot of them are
um or or were cops or I kind of feel
like there's not all of them because
there's exceptions
but I do kind of feel like people that
tend to become serial killers they have
a very
some of them have like a really like
authoritarian kind of mindset or they
enjoy that kind of thing
I think that's only part of it I think
what it is is that
most guys
that have the urges of a serial killer
don't have and don't have enough
experience or enough training or
confidence to actually kill the three
it's a session that you need to become a
killer they get caught before that most
of them
so the guys that make it to three plus
killings are guys that have some kind of
a training philosophy in their
background or the confidence that they
need to do it then sometimes they get
that from the police and military
I mean look at all what's his name
original Night Stalker D'Angelo that's
who I was thinking of
D'Angelo he was doing [ __ ] that [ __ ]
dudes in Delta Force wouldn't try to
pull off
sneaking into people's houses to set the
house up so he could come in later at
night when both the people are in there
and then do a takeover
that's a [ __ ] risky ass Mission but
he'd do it he'd stay in the houses for
[ __ ] hours eating their [ __ ] [ __ ]
going to rape the woman and go make fun
of the dude and go back to the FNAF kids
dishes on the dude's back like if I hear
these rattling but I'm gonna kill her
yeah yeah and and he wasn't a [ __ ] he
was a big dude he's mean he went in
there not anymore he's not no not
anymore
mean little dick [ __ ] and uh he
the
he never would have had the balls to do
that if he hadn't been a cop
I think it was military too wasn't he or
just a cop yeah I think he was both
actually now if I'm remembering
correctly he knew that you could sneak
around with a gun in the middle of the
night in people's backyards and get into
a house silently and the neighbors would
never know
if you set it up right so he had that
confidence
I mean I learned that in Korea there'd
be 50 of us in the [ __ ] platoon
wearing body armor [ __ ] helmets I was
carrying an M60 [ __ ] bell-fed machine
gun
and we will walk through korean's
backyards all night long climbing their
fences and everything 50 of us in a
[ __ ] in a ranger file and not a
single light turn on in the middle of
night you would think 50 men would be
heard
no and we weren't that quiet
climbing over their fences and [ __ ]
never saw never saw us
50 heavily armed dudes and body armor
back in the 90s
it was just part of our [ __ ] training
and our patrols going one place to the
next there just happened to be villages
in the way we just went right through
them
you know Henry vampir said have you read
Catherine ramsland's work that's who I
was just talking about
um she wrote a book called Confessions
of a serial killer yeah she corresponded
with BTK for a really long time thank
you Katie thank you happy birthday Jenny
from Pat and Cat you guys are amazing
and we're happy to celebrate a part of
it with you guys oh thank you so much
that's awesome but yeah that's who I was
thinking of um Catherine ramsland yeah
Our Friend Sophie sent me that book and
I'm like I'm fascinated by serial
killers because they're the way that
their brains work is just so alien
and that's interesting to me it's
horrifying but it's also kind of
interesting so like reading his letters
and like the things that he thought
about himself and the things that he
thought about what he was doing
um really like weirded me out like the
whole time I was reading that it was
kind of like blowing my mind I was just
kind of like holy [ __ ] like how can
anybody like how can anybody's brain be
that [ __ ] different from my brain
because I was like I have no idea like
where you're coming from with that
you know what I mean [ __ ] crazy crazy
I think a lot each one's a little bit
different they are yeah so that was just
him but yeah
Danny says so is tomorrow's movie going
to be alligator probably I was just
talking about that earlier I think it's
still on shutter if it's not on shutter
it's probably on another streaming
service
I mean if we have to pay for it I guess
we will but I was just like I don't know
we were watching chud and I was like man
I kind of want to watch alligator again
because I haven't seen that since I was
a kid and I remember like scaring the
[ __ ] out of me and so I kind of wanted
to watch it again and I think shutter
has it but maybe not anymore I'm not
really sure but I have to check so
hopefully it'll be that we'll find it
we'll find it somehow so you seem like
you're winding it down get real hot he's
winding down all right so thank you
everybody for dropping by and talking
about haunting and celebrating my
birthday with me and we'll be back
tomorrow probably talking about
alligator from 1980 because that's kind
of what I want to watch this evening so
that should be fun so hopefully you guys
will hang out with us again tomorrow 6
p.m Eastern Standard Time and we will
see you guys again tomorrow
bye